tu t'en cache pas tu vis avec christina
milian une chanteuse et comédienne
américaine et tous les deux c'est
l'amour fou tu me racontait que ce qui
vous avait rapproché avant tout c'est
l'amour des carreaux vous êtes tous les
deux âgés l'erf a signé le break te dire
ça fait roi je suis propre je supportais
jamais fatigué fort et vous avoue face à
roquettes pour ceux qui connaissent pas
la crise nous avons officialisé votre là
tant que 2010 cette étude le seimat
c'est pas pour rien qu'on surnomme dans
le milieu l'inspecteur ba ba aa aia et
un mois avant l'officialisation il ya
quelque chose qui m'a déjà mis la puce à
l'oreille
1 je vous le dis vous posiez des gens au
centre dans une boîte de nuit à saint
tropez et là je me suis dit ah
curieuse méthode et sur instagram
christina écrivait meet my birthday to
make my birthday twin qui veut dire j'ai
mangé de la viande de la viande pour mon
anniversaire
que signifie cette mascarade ce qui veut
dire en anglais pulsé matt bobo matt
pokora des graves beau j'aimerais bien
le pechoux le 28 juillet dernier c'est
l'événement tu annonces sur instagram
que tu vas devenir papa
ça c'était fou moi j'étais comme un fou
tu as déclaré que l'accouchement devrait
intervenir pendant une pause de ta
tournée alors on va regarder les dates
de sa tournée dans son fils aurait
naître entre le 20 décembre et le 5 mars
ouais c'est un scorpion à son ans et j
pierre suesser je sais que maintenant
vous êtes à la recherche du prénom idéal
tu as dit qu'il fallait que ça sonne
aussi bien en français qu'en anglais
mais est-ce que la prononciation soit
proche donc à mon avis si je peux donner
un conseil il faut que tu vas pas lui
qui me mohamed
[Rires]
sinon tu me mohamed espère sec
voilà donc c'est vrai si si c'est génial
franchement j'adore matmos moment je
suis très heureux pour toi je te le dis
et voilà en plus tentant de prendre
comme ça vous êtes ces poudres en
religion ça quoi c'est vrai vous ça va
vous arriver un jour vous allez voir de
quoi
alors l'amour ou daho d'accoucher à
l'épaule est-ce que tu as une idée pour
le prénom du bébé ou pas du tout notes
de trois idées mais mais c'est encore
toujours sur la prononciation j'ai
vraiment envie que ça sonne aussi bien
en français qu'en anglais avec la
prononciation soit super proche produits
retomber dans des trucs à rougir aux
jeunes émules avec kevin à babi mahmoud
abbas les marmots de but j'adore c'est
moi j'aime beaucoup aussi samar hajj ali
si tu vas te faut couper voilà c'est
elle très mal jimmy mahmoud taha